foreign
[Music]
until he was given a chance you know
that was some show you put on out there
today
something more you like to fight if I
have to I can make you five thousand
dollars got you interested huh
so what they got rules yeah you lose you
get nothing go make some money
how come I never heard of you oh fast
I've never heard of you either
looks like Hobbies got a winner it's the
real thing I'm sorry it's July like July
yeah make sure she gets home okay thank
you Sean oh you called me Shawna good
night
now every fight he's a big dude don't
get too close yeah thanks for that
brings him closer what are you doing
here I was just walking by against the
past two hours hoping to show up to the
life he's always wanted
where are we going we're in a hundred
thousand dollar Mercedes that's what
we're going but everything has its price
those guys they run this whole city we
lost a lot of money betting on you to
get beat tonight
well maybe about the right way next time
this spring maybe we should put your man
in one of our fights a big fight half a
million dollars to the winner
[Music]
some risks are worth taking what's going
on I'm facing all my money against us
some dreams why would you do that we're
talking real money are worth fighting
for you think I don't understand I'm
nothing
I get it I ain't worth nothing
but the only way I'm gonna lose is if
somebody beats me
20 skills
[Music]
don't make us come looking for you you
don't scare me
thank you
around here
when the lights go down the real action
begins ready
[Applause]
but for newcomer Jake Tyler Mr Tyler
there's this party night see you there
yeah in this world you can't get much
better than this you don't get to choose
your battles you ready the hell out of
here man I'm not fighting what the hell
you doing here
now for the bad news It's gotta end
the only time you're happy is when
you're hurting people what are you gonna
do about it Jake wait
I'm gonna stop this guy
people who come here for the wrong
reasons they never last look like Claire
everyone up what do I do learn quickly
it's not just you Jake everyone has the
fight you can do what I can never do
[Applause]
I'm not doing
this is my fight
welcome Warriors of the world today
you've become part of a tradition that
began hundreds of years ago the Kumite
was first used
the black dragon Society to measure the
fighting skills and spirit of its
members every five years the best
fighters in its rights would face each
other in full contact
with one winner emerging as the superior
Warrior the Champs
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to know the toughest man in the
planet is
that's what we're gonna find out
friend it's me pop what are you doing
here Tommy's back did you say if he
wants to see me
I'm proud of you Tommy what you did for
that kid in the tank what was I supposed
to do let him drown Tommy Reardon you
saved my life look Brendan the bank has
got to go by the new appraisal figures
you're upside down on your mortgage how
much do you need I can come here for
long Frank I was hoping that he would
train me are you serious
thought we agreed that we weren't going
to raise our children in a family
Brennan you're a teacher you got no
business in the ring with those animals
actually I used to be one of those
islands
I forgot to put that down in my
application
there's this big tournament
top 16 middleweights in the world and it
takes all I'm
sure
I need this I got a family to protect
everything I do is for them what's going
on up here Daddy is now a princess
Mom needed you I needed you you're my
big brother you bailed on me I was a 16
year old kid what the hell did I know
you had a choice okay you had a choice
sensation and
Colin the physics teacher they pulled
off a miracle
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you saying I can do this
impossible
Championship tonight
[Music]
thank you
when Japan
China
Rose still fight against them
but only one man
a warrior Legend
[Music]
conquered and oppressed
lost his honor
[Music]
Tommy yam as
greatest martial arts master of a
generation
Yip Man
[Music]
foreign
but a vicious crime Lord
see all that all that is mine is
bringing Terror to the streets
[Music]
come on let's go and he is the only one
who can step up
to bring him down tonight there's a new
kid in town
because that's gonna be breaking when he
hit I'm not sure I approve of The
Company You Keep Mr bone me neither
I have a fighter so we're looking to sit
at the grown-ups table are we five
million dollars the fight is on never
said I would fight you are in a fight or
somebody's gonna be dead I am the
punishment of God
you had not committed great sins
God would not have sent a punishment
like me upon you
[Music]
I don't like people to say no to me
maybe you should get used to it
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
Ace and Jim are the only ones making
money off your blood we gotta make the
Billy get into a globe
one more fight what if I can't do this
we can I want to make this right get his
back
[Music]
rubber bands
[Applause]
it's good
oh hey principal Badger you're late
again you're my parents teacher of the
year that was 10 years ago it feels like
eight though right
yeah several of you already know
Wilkinson High School's been operating
at a budget deficit we are cutting all
extracurricular activities excuse me
everyone's quit on these kids we have to
cut 48 000 or raise the money oh and
who's gonna do that we will
exactly is the plan how about we work
out a plan in my apartment and dinner
also happens to be around so we just do
both
I gotta figure this thing out yeah right
after you watch the fight
10 grand for that performance you made
10 grand for that fight he lost everyone
it would have been 50.
I want to fight mixed martial arts this
is crazy do you even know how to do that
no no I do not but it was a really good
wrestler in college I think I can do
this let's see what you got which guy am
I fighting oh come on I can't fight two
guys I can't train a 42 year old biology
teacher you want to be a fighter start
in the cage is that a chicken this is
bottom level MMA you're gonna follow in
the footsteps of all those great
warriors that put fear in the hearts of
their opponents
foreign
you know what you're not cutting
anything that's the first installment
right there you're getting beat up in
your bathing suit you are embarrassing
the school this wasn't plan a but I
don't know what else to do
I don't make an effort nothing's ever
gonna change
[Music]
let's get our story straight uh Derek
did it
[Music]
why are you teaching this kids if you go
through with it what am I teaching them
if I don't
all right
everyone's gonna be able to do this you
can quit right now
and everything we worked for will have
been accomplished our students they're
inspired
what if I dunk this ball in that hoop
and you have dinner with me at my house
deal no no that's cheating the dreams
are about to come true
go in
[Music]
I'm just 12 years old
watch my parents die
I'm in walked up to her car
what do you think it's going to my
father's face
and shot him
he never saw me
but I saw him
according to this you're barely passing
and you haven't even started your
community service
can take a third victim of that son your
grandfather and I have a possible
solution your father's old friend Reggie
runs that doji this is the name judge
our floor long time you'll be on it and
you're cleaning it so I'm your janitor
you're here because you made the wrong
choices I'm
Michael here uh Reggie's niece right I
want to show you something
we want the best fighters inside this
cage no weight class or a fight and get
out of my office
I'm not training you so you can go up
and fight in some circus and killed my
parents
chance of doing what
I want to know something funny I can
carry uh and nobody would care
notice these guys that want you to me
they'll be able to help you with your
ground game this is the tournament of
all tournaments
I know you think that you need to do
this
guys I can't meet me I don't care about
his reputation you can do for them all
right right we got a real David versus
goliathan tonight baby
I think it's going to be a great fight I
don't know why everybody's not coming to
this fight Pay-Per-View is pulling back
on the promotion we're not selling
tickets we have a deal or we don't have
a deal we need a gimmick what Good's a
deal if nobody's making any money time
up think he has a handicap no the other
guy has a handicap if he cannot control
himself breathe you know the Escape
breathe is always an escape you're check
bounced my check the martial arts of
life I can't make the rent you have no
cash there's one rule put the other guy
down just call him you calm down just
wanna have a drink
foreign
looking for trouble what happened bad
boy jumped on a movie star what about
you nobody knows who I am the man
distracted is a man defeated it's an
invitation from Chad Frank who trained
people to fight I trained people to
Prevail tell them your Training Method
the fight is before a fight three
marbles each fighter has a two and three
odds of choosing the white marble white
marbles a pass what if he picks the
black marble black marble is a handicap
who imposes the terms of the battle will
impose the terms of the peace each
fighter will take a marble should he
pick a white marble he'll be given a
pass you draw the black marble you're
either gonna have one arm tied to your
body or potentially both arms tied to
your body you stole my idea you can't
copyright an idea he has a document of
his training regime that he's used for
many years you want to make some money
fight on the undercar it's worth a
quarter of a mill competition is
weakening what about the Fighter's
family what do they eat the fight is
fixed we pick who gets the white marble
who gets to pass tonight you I'm ending
the charade
talk to you you think you're going to
the ring you're going nowhere Mike
you're going nowhere
there is no situation you could not
Escape
you know the Escape
[Applause]
sucking cash out of me for months 62k
the way I figured his debts are you're
dead
my main event this year is called the
Battle Royale you fight and you fight to
win I don't fight anymore but like
you've got some kind of choice
I'm only doing this to Scott is dead
he's clear so we're talking about known
fights and I'm out yeah that's what they
are saying this is not in Queensbury you
gotta get with wrestling holes Judo Jiu
Jitsu you don't understand these
takedowns he ain't gonna last one round
you don't need to do this it's not like
how it was before I'm surprised they
fight dirty the crowd is getting used to
you waiting so it's a perfect
opportunity to take a few times it
wasn't part of our deal you fight when I
tell you to fight
[Music]
into this
I don't train Fighters I fight for all
the wrong reasons because I'm pissed off
when I get out there
I only need like two grand and we could
get out of here you know you want to
make money girl it's the payload right
here
50 bucks what now I need to borrow some
money I'm sorry Tori honestly I could
care less if I was dead
or down the street as she died in fight
valley
I'm not looking to change anyone
I'm looking to kill someone
you're gonna hear ask him because you
don't know how to fight
[Music]
[Applause]
higher
[Music]